- Oh wow, that's just heavy!
You can feel all that cheese on there.
This was worth every single
minute of the trek to get here.
(upbeat percussive music)
Good morning everyone, it's Mark Wiens
with Migrationology.com in New York City.
I'm loving the view of
the city this morning.
Today, we're gonna head over to Brooklyn
and on our way first to eat
at a famous pizza place.
Today, you could say I'm on
a bit of a pizza pilgrimage.
We're on our way to the
subway and should be
about a 40 minute ride or
so, maybe it will take us
about an hour to get to
Brooklyn to the pizza place.
(lively reggae music)
We're going all the
way from 34th street...
Where is that?
Where is 34th street?
Here, Harold Square, all
the way over to Brooklyn.
And we're gonna get off on Avenue J.
(lively reggae music)
That took exactly 40 minutes
and according to Google Maps,
it says Di Fara is a one
minute walk from here.
I'm getting excited.
(lively reggae music)
Right now it's right at 11:30 a.m.,
so it's about 30 minutes
til they open at noon.
Looks like I'm the first
one here today, oh yeah!
I'm in a little bit of
a dilemma right now.
I'm not sure whether I should order
the regular pie, which
is a circular pizza.
Or the square pie.
People both say that they are amazing.
Some people like the square pie,
some people like the circle, regular pie.
I think I might have to keep
it classic with the circle pie.
That's my thought before they open.
Can I get one regular pie?
- [Man] Okay.
- [Mark] With half pepperoni?
- [Man] Of course, what's the name?
- [Mark] Mark.
- [Man] Okay Mark, about 10 minutes.
- [Mark] Thank you very much.
- [Man] Al, half pepperoni, Al!
And she's making us do more work.
Hey Mark!
- [Mark] Thank you.
- [Man] There you go.
- [Mark] Thank you,
can we get it in a box?
- [Man] Yeah, if you want.
- [Mark] Yes please.
- [Man] It's 31.
- I think Ying and I will take it to go.
So I put it in a box.
This is fresh out of the
oven and I don't wanna...
I do love my chili but I think I'll
put it on the side for now.
Just put a bunch of chili
on the side for later.
And they do have a couple
of tables and seats inside,
but with a box of pizza this big
there was just no space to sit down.
So I decided to get it to go, but I cannot
walk far to taste it while
it's hot and fresh right now.
I have to taste my
first piece immediately!
And I would just like to
really quickly mention
that Dom DeMarco, who is
the pizza legend at Di Fara.
And he is a literally, a pizza hero.
And I saw him on a TV program from Vice TV
at this place making the pizza.
And he looked like he had so much passion
and just an amazing, an amazing man.
He was not making the
pizza today when I came.
So I was a little bit
disappointed, but that's okay.
I am still very happy it's
still within his family.
Okay, let me just open this up.
Oh, that aroma!
And what I loved is that
after it came out of the oven
he immediately, whoa that is a heavy box.
He immediately, as it came
out of the oven, he took
a handful of basil and he
chopped it up using scissors.
So you can smell that aroma of
the fresh basil all over it.
I'm gonna start with
this piece right here.
Just the regular cheese
with lots of basil on it.
And you can see that oil and
that oh, it's hot and fresh!
Oh and there's a little corner
of pepperoni on here as well.
Oh wow, that's just heavy!
You can feel all that cheese on there.
That is amazing!
That is outstanding!
Okay, this was worth every single minute
of the trek to get here.
Oh, that crust paired with that cheese.
The ratio is beautiful and it just gushes
with that olive oil and you can taste
that fresh basil chopped on there.
And the cheese it's salty but not
too salty, it's perfectly salty.
The tomato sauce is not very tart
it has more of like a
sweet tomato-y flavor.
Oh, you can just see that cheese and sauce
oozing out of the crust
when I take a bite,
when it condenses in there.
So that cheese is just a perfect
melted-ness mixed with that sauce.
This is a beautiful thing.
Next up, I have to go for the pepperoni.
This place is legendary for a reason.
It's so good!
The combination, the simple
combination of ingredients
but just made perfectly
and cooked perfectly.
I know one of the things
that they really stress
is how it's cooked and the done-ness.
So it is crispy on the
bottom but not burnt.
It is just a beautiful
golden, lightly blackened,
crispy-ness on the bottom,
gooey on the inside
where that sauce meets the cheese.
It's just incredibly good.
(lively reggae music)
After eating two pieces of
pizza, then we ended up walking
over to the nearest park to sit down
and to enjoy the rest of the pizza.
And so we made it to the park
and immediately as you open
the cover of that box
you can smell that basil.
That basil makes all the difference.
Okay, I'm gonna go for
this piece over here.
This is mostly a cheese piece just
with a few cut-outs of pepperoni.
Okay, and it's not so hot anymore
but I think it's still gonna be amazing.
Yeah, that is just a brilliant
combination of flavors.
A brilliant pizza.
It was definitely better when
I had that very first piece.
Right out of the oven when
the cheese was sloppy.
I'm gonna go ahead and dip in that chili.
Or maybe I'll unfold and
just sort of go down.
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
I think I would have to say that I enjoyed
the regular pizza, no
pepperoni, just the pizza
with cheese and the basil on it the most.
That was the best.
Just that basil, just
increased the flavor.
And that olive oil, it was fantastic.
And although I didn't have a chance
to see Mr. Dom, the
legend, making the pizza
I still could feel the passion
and the love of pizza at Di Fara.
Walking through the neighborhood,
it's a really nice
neighborhood here in Brooklyn.
And I just looked up the
directions, we are on our way
over to a different subway station
called Flatbush, next to Brooklyn college.
And we're gonna take
that a little bit north
and head next to eat some Caribbean food.
(lively reggae music)
So we're heading just a couple stations
from Flatbush to President Station.
(lively reggae music)
This restaurant is called Gloria's.
And they serve Caribbean food.
And I think, this is Brooklyn,
but I think this area
is called Crown Heights.
And as soon as I entered
the door you could just
smell the aroma of the spices in here.
And they do have a few tables
within this little restaurant,
it's a small restaurant but
it has some nice high tables.
And so we sat in the corner here.
And I got the large portion and it's huge!
That is heavy!
And I got the chicken curry.
Oh, that steam!
That steam was ridiculous,
it smells so good!
It came with rice and peas,
and this is a side of pumpkin.
And I'm not sure, I think she gave me
some kind of a vegetable
which was called like
cam-boo-la or something like that,
I can't even remember the
name but that's what I tried.
And then Ying got the fish curry.
Oh Ying, that looks awesome.
A whole fish steak and that
curry smells incredible.
And then some kind of,
maybe collard greens
and mixed vegetables.
Grab my fork, ah I cannot
wait it smells so good!
Okay I gotta begin with
this chicken curry.
Oh and let me mix it with some of that.
That chicken curry...
It's so hot and fresh.
And the spice blend is superb.
You can taste, I think,
some cumin in there.
And maybe some garlic and ginger.
And then that vegetable that's like a...
It's some kind of puréed vegetable.
I don't know what that
vegetable is but it's awesome!
It sort of has a little
bit of a spinach-y...
That sort of slimy,
spinach-y texture to it.
But at the same time it's puréed.
It has a little bit of a sour taste to it.
And that is amazing, that
vegetable is awesome.
And then with that red rice on the bottom.
And then mixed in with the spices
from the chicken curry, wow!
That is absolutely a
sensational mixture of food.
Okay now let me try for
some of that pumpkin.
Whoa, mmm-hmm.
It's so nice and sweet and
then balanced by being salty.
It's a creamy purée as well
and you can taste a little bit
of those pumpkin fibers in
there as well, it's wonderful.
And then it's lightly spiced,
maybe I can taste a little bit
of the pepper in there or maybe that's
coming from the curry that's mixed in.
I'm very happy with this
meal in front of me.
This chicken curry is
just absolutely awesome.
And I love how it's all mixed together
within this tray as well,
you get little bites of...
Well you get rice, then
you get bites of that curry
with all those spices, then
you get that creamy vegetable,
and then the sweetness from the pumpkin.
It all just works together.
I'm gonna get everything in one bite.
Yeah.
Let me taste the fish curry.
Oh, that's very firm.
Look at all that spice!
Maybe it's king fish?
And then that beautiful
blend of spices again.
You can taste the tomato,
it's a little bit spicy.
And that blend of dry spices in there
just is fantastically
delicious, so much flavor.
I'm so full right now that
was so hardy and so flavorful.
And the combination,
actually I really liked it.
'Cause the chicken curry is
full of spice and turmeric.
And I loved it with that pumpkin
because you get that sweet
touch mixed in by that
naturally sweetness.
You've got that creamy vegetable
and then all on a bed of rice.
Awesome place, the
owners are very friendly.
And she told me that the restaurant
serves mainly Trinidad style food.
It's worth making the trip out here
to Crown Heights Brooklyn for
some delicious Caribbean food.
(lively reggae music)
Just 30 minutes ago we were in
what felt like almost the Caribbean.
Eating delicious Trinidad food.
And now back into the middle of Manhattan.
Actually I'm still kind
of full from lunch,
so I think I'm gonna end the vlog
for today right here, and call it a day.
But again, I just wanna
emphasize the reason why
I love New York City so
much and why it's such
an amazing city is
because of the diversity,
it's such an incredible melting pot.
Alright, that's it for today's vlog
see you on the next video,
thank you again for watching.